[Music]
all right we head now to the State of
Arizona Republican gubernatorial
candidate Kerry Lake and Senate
candidate Blake Masters they are
continuing to put Democrats into panic
mode and there he was the anointed one
Barack Obama out in Arizona pretty angry
on the campaign Trail this time
campaigning against them earlier today
here with reaction gubernatorial
candidate Carrie Lake she has a a pretty
big lead over her opponent and also
Blake Masters who got some great news
this week not only did the libertarian
that was running for the senate in
Arizona drop out of the race but the
that libertarian candidate endorsed
Blake Masters uh good to see you both
Kari let me start with you I'm sure
you're all upset that Barack Obama went
out there to campaign against you
uh first it was Liz Cheney last week and
I just laughed that off and now I'm
living rent free and Barack Obama's mind
and then Eric Holder today
but I was a little concerned today I'm
going to be honest when I saw Hillary
Clinton
bad-mouthing me and Sheila she looked
angry and actually scared and and uh
just a completely unrelated I want you
to know just in case you're wondering
I'm in perfect health my brakes on my
car in good shape and I'm not suicidal
and we're gonna win this thing on
Tuesday I think one of the things that
has endeared you to the people of
Arizona and around the country is you
got a great sense of humor you got a
good comeback for everything uh Blake
Masters this is big news for you because
look in the polls that I was seeing it
was four five six percent the
libertarian was drawing
um those are votes against Mark Kelly
Mark Kelly is a rubber stamp for all
things Chuck Schumer and Joe Biden he
has been on the Forefront of of
supporting every bit of the agenda that
they are advocating and he hasn't lifted
a finger to secure the Border uh in your
state I would say now that you are are
the odds on favorite because of this
endorsement this is a big deal
it is a big deal Sean and you know I'm
honored that the libertarian candidate I
think you graciously bowed out honored
to have his endorsement it's a good
boost of momentum here and we've got all
the momentum in this race Mark Kelly
he's floundering he is desperate I think
Katie Hobbs is desperate too they're so
desperate they don't want to talk about
their own ideas they don't want to talk
about their own track records so what do
they do they dust off Barack Obama they
drag this guy out of retirement to come
and distract everybody right he talks
about how we're the main reason he's
angry is because he likes his schedule
he doesn't feel like working every day
you know he's mad that he has to get up
and do the work because Joe Biden can't
do it and nobody wants to be he barely
showed up they almost filled a high
school gymnasium they almost filled a
high school gym I mean it was low energy
it was pathetic uh
you know Curry you said something that
you take up a lot of space in people's
heads it's that a lot of politicians are
afraid to speak their mind you're not
and that I think has defined your race
because I think the people in Arizona
find it refreshing frankly
yeah I think people Sean are tired of
being silenced by the news tired of
being silenced by big Tech tired of
worrying about if they speak Common
Sense they're going to be canceled and
I'm seeing a lot of people who are just
saying this is the time for us to stand
up and speak out if we don't it's going
to be too late and and that's why we're
seeing in our polling the Latinos are
coming our way the soccer moms are
coming our way the Suburban moms are
coming our way because they're worried
about real issues like crime the wide
open border the fentanyl crisis the
brainwashing of their kids in school and
they realize this is the election when
we can finally solve these problems you
know one of the things that I noticed
when I was out in Arizona with both of
you is that you know you're you're very
much like a team what Kari what you're
going to do on the state level and Blake
what you'll do in Washington uh really
will complement you know service for the
people in Arizona you don't see that in
every state I we just had it we just saw
with governor sununu and and general
Bolduc who's now leading in that race
which is a surprise to a lot of people
but if you win your race if Bulldog wins
of Herschel wins of Oz wins
um I mean this could be a blowout and
but yet they're all very close races
Blake what's your take
you know I think we could easily end up
with 54 Senate seats here if not more
and it is important right when I'm in
the Senate I'm going to be working with
Governor Kerry Lake you know Kerry
Lake's going to pull power back from
Washington D.C to the states well I'm
going to help push that power back from
you know from D.C to the states we have
to work together it helps that we're
friends it helps that we're running on
this America First agenda right and our
opponents are so bad Katie Hobbs is
probably the worst candidate in the
country to John fetterman in
Pennsylvania I agree and Mark Kelly's
right there with them I mean this guy
votes in lockstep for Joe Biden's agenda
what kind of guy promises the good
people of Arizona to be an independent
only to get to DC and surrender to Chuck
Schumer and vote for open borders and
Fentanyl and 300 000 illegals coming
through every month sorry this guy needs
to be fired and that's what we're going
to do next Tuesday you get the last 20
seconds Carly Lake
well I I think we have a real
opportunity Arizona to get things back
on track here everyone wants a secure
border everybody wants Safe Streets and
they know I'm going to be working for
the people of Arizona thank you Sean for
having us on it's great to have you this
election is simple it's about inflation
it's about record high gas prices open
borders it's about defund dismantle no
bail laws Safety and Security for the
American people it's about walk
education or Reading Writing Math
Science and History and computers it's
that simple uh Blake thank you Curry
thank you